what kept happening and cut off you have
your camera set before I sit down Alba
Erickson it's her name of her last part
Tara I'm Greg in true complete a yes
Tara Erickson on YouTube and it's
instagrams ago and Twitter the charities
Matt yep you should follow her hashtag
this idiot that truth is what her
parents called her anyway yeah become
part of my hashtag idiot army become
part of a national India tarnish she's
back on the channel she's gonna get
enough with a Greg inator is what she
told me around she walked through that
door I'm quoting her word for word I did
Mark Hamill he Frank Star Wars fans with
epic surprise for force for change you
know Mark Hamill is right yeah yeah he
played Han Solo some student as an I'm
better and I need you to give me your
greatest no that's really good what I
want you to channel your inner Mark
Hamill hood short all people like not
anymore
oh my god
[Applause]
oh hey guys
is it don't miss your opportunity to be
a force for change
enter now for your chance to win three
once-in-a-lifetime experiences and I'm
throwing in a bonus prize enter and
we're also being running to join me for
lunch in La Leche you get two tickets to
a pre-screening of Star Wars the last
Jedi it's no surprise that the Star Wars
community has stepped up big once again
so it's a small thank you I've rounded
up a few super fans for something
special they think they're here to read
some classic Star Wars lines for a video
celebrating the 40th anniversary but
what they don't know that I'll be there
surprise co-star in other words it's a
trap all right well then some questions
all right you have a favorite character
and yes obi-wan Kenobi by far because in
a new hope he's referred to as Ben
Kenobi hi my name is done we shouldn't
lose the Dark Side care absolutely Darth
Vader
I got a active actually I've got
Imperial TIE fighters and I got this dot
say a lightsaber ll I call Brandon and
you have a favorite of the movies rub
one
yam down reinvest our film I've ever
seen I won't be here to here ah thing
we're going to do is put you in a scene
from the movie right Luke is looking at
you know twin sons of powder we hope
he's thinking about how much you want to
get off planet in two three two one
action you're out there and you're
looking at your desk and you know
something oh my god you're destined to
have to change
[Laughter]
with you oh you're gonna be with the
duel with starfish going to bring in
another actor can do his best to give
you mine spare will complete all right
sorry got nothing damn you got your wine
charging away oh my god after your
father he probably hurt before
all right there I'll start yeah yeah you
have the first time right action obi-wan
never told you what happened to your
father boy told me enough he told me you
little more striking in fact Morgan
[Laughter]
laughs yeah that's not a father
Skywalker yeah and the lightsaber we're
gonna have another actor come in and
he's going to try and best to do kind of
like a little thing here we go
three two one hatched arias better
looking girl this close to Luke
Skywalker hold that lightsaber out and
finally you have a chance to meet your
shooter I don't flip out
Oh mad little bit
that came with a hand did you bring that
tune finally so I'm like man you than I
do in the movies alright brings you to
see where you actually say that I am
your father Luke I one more time
remember you click alone in the
completely blind side you ever expect it
has no idea didn't see this guy so I'm
really really Luke and your father oh
that's impossible you can't be dad oh my
God he's like bro after owe me one oh if
your father's like Luke Center you'd be
losing no one's my favorite it bless me
and more about ready how this looks in a
strong for UNICEF and Starlight
Children's Foundation click the link
enter and stay tuned after all pretty
roots - yeah it's probably another
character
[Music]
I love it Oh maze is so cool
you could win all three yeah I saw the
was last year Harrison Ford did one over
for Skype and four people skyping in
John boyega did one very similar to what
Mark Hamill just that I was just
watching celebrities prank their fans so
good they could do what's up the kid
been with my favorite why because he did
so generally high music oh yeah oh my
god oh do anything everyone else was
just like they were still cool and
excited but the one kid he was just so
sweet amaze me he's cute I would get
serious nipple chill that this happened
would be like my first reaction I don't
know why nobody would screaming you
never choke I would have lost my mind
into my class you scream on a daily
basis though I do he's right you're
screaming at me break out into screaming
I do
I just got break out into some people
break out the song I break out yeah and
that's your thing so it makes sense if
you scream right I'm Mark Hamill right
then what are you gonna do I would take
your head and put it over my nipples
just a nice well I would have freaked
out I just grabbed your head and just
put your palm oh god help at all and
then he would kick me off and that would
be a deleted take for the force for
change
yeah project for you never serve it I'm
wondering something cuz he's back in the
new Star Wars movie and there was to be
like the main character one of the main
characters in it sound a little messed
up because Mark Hamill's rather old now
yeah he's put on some weight yeah which
is understandable that Mark Hamill as an
aging actor would put on weight mmm-hmm
why is Luke Skywalker heavy he's just on
an island right he's a Jedi yeah where
does he find the time
she says light on her legs just start I
mean there is a lot of calories and
yeah okay it's a lot of sugar and it's a
lot of carbs
doc people don't know and people know
they think I'm healthy
it'll be all right yeah but we've got a
walker Mike some pineapples a little too
much yeah you're sleeping on on leaves
and sand okay you don't get a lot of
sleep you don't get a lot of sleep you
start gaining weight and you start not
sleeping you start damming pineapple
every day you're gonna put on some
pounds Gregory and if you're like wow
you don't probably of where they are
fine and bananas okay that's a lot of
sugar in him too so this is a character
choice was with Tara telling us it's a
it's a character decision they asked him
to lose weight he said no it makes more
sense if Luke Skywalker put on some
weight and all the walking on foot
traveling he never makes sense it makes
sense because you get hungry when you're
doing the walking and you're not
sleeping lifesaver training and stuff it
would make sense that he gained weight
instead of state then yeah because you
know sometimes you need a little you
know a reservoir of fat in there to keep
you going
okay he'd burn calories during the day
then at night he's not getting sleep and
yeah he's just pounding a lot of island
fruit this is good this is good you have
restored my face and Stouffer's what
this next one is no problem maybe they
just leave the eye the fat out what
right oh that would be good you know
they do opens like the aging stuff Aries
mean DHD fat and they do like gain
weight stuff in movies like CGI fat yeah
maybe a beaters don't come on baby yeah
if you just take it away from people
yeah now it looks like old school yeah
well why are these people getting buff
for all these superhero films they could
just CGI their body into looking amazing
or they just look normal to not make it
feel so awful about the rest of our
lives about that we don't want them to
know what I look hot when I've learned
from all action movies is that if you're
but you can survive anything that's what
the Fast and the Furious films have
taught me feel it wow I could bounce
something off of that like soft Martian
I like a soft marshmallow with
definitely not balanced itself who's the
biggest celebrity you've met besides me
of course yeah besides you that's a good
question
hold on who have I met Joel Osteen no
ma'am
Jean smart was in a movie I was in she's
awesome she was in fargo season two and
she was amazing but she's just a lot of
people unknown Jean smart is but it's
just woke her up if you don't shoot a
movie I was in she played she was I was
famous person I met is the person a lot
of people don't have okay all right okay
fine
who have I met Oh famous people weird I
have a bad memory
hold on I know this is taking up tape
but give me a second she thought for so
long as a camera ended up cutting we cut
it's kind of organic but organically I
didn't take my gingko biloba today
because I forgot is that a joke double
Lobo are you intentionally saying that
with gingko biloba I have yet to learn
how your sense of humor actually works
in the word worth video were filming it
working not sure it works like this
I forgot to take my gingko biloba and
yeah that's how I always thought that
whatever no okay I know but it's it
because you can catch her at the Comedy
Store committed rate I would know how to
say it
Alma for us in this video uh let's just
move right along okay ah like how you're
like whale let me let me know okay you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
know what else you can do you can click
that notification bill two things you
got to do in order to watch videos
online we recently launched the patreon
go check it out we've created throwing
Karen Ericson she's on YouTube we're
gonna do a video for her channel what
one better go check it out then
immediately she has sketches and other
funny stuff on there she recently
started doing reactions as well hey what
do you know on the other person doing
actions that's all I ever wanted for you
to now have a patreon so you know just
do it just do both ring ring bell ballon
and go to patreon for Devin Jim Jim -
sure follow her on Instagram no bikini
pics I look not they're non-existent
guys you don't want to see any of that
trust me yeah you trust me